i'm very excited about this how are you
i'm doing good man thanks for having me
all right let's just jump right into it
in 2008 2009 global financial crisis
happens that's when you started gelt i
believe correct that's when we got uh
did you think
the housing bubble is bursting now's a
good time to invest in real estate and i
should get in and it was like a master
plan or was it like
ah i need to do something this is
interesting let me get started it just
happened to be a good time how much of
it was intentional versus uh
serendipitous so the intentional part
was um my cousin was out in a city
called bakersfield california two hours
north of la and they they got hit by the
housing bust even first before la
started dropping and we he said wow
these like four unit buildings that
previously sold for 500 grand we could
pick up for 150 grand so they were 25
cents on the dollar-ish and i'm like
it's a no-brainer if you could rent out
like two of the units you're cash
flowing three of three or four units
you're cash flowing like a pig so sort
of like you know we didn't plan on
building a huge enterprise but we
started with one and it seemed like a
good opportunity and they were like oh
this is pretty cool then we did another
one and another one and just built on
itself you know what were the mistakes
you made in the first one everyone makes
mistakes in the beginning what were the
things that you look back now you're
like man i was so dumb i didn't know x
yeah i think some of the most important
lessons we learned early on were a just
because something's cheap doesn't make
it a good investment so these buildings
were in the roughest parts of town it
was all we could have afforded back in
the day and you know it was great
learning experience cutting our teeth
you know renovating these dilapidated
buildings leasing them out but the
tenants were really rough on the units
uh we dealt with a lot of uh vacancy
issues section eight kind of tenants it
was just a different ball ball game and
then we started you know buying in
little higher quality areas and on paper
the returns didn't look as good but they
actually were much better the returns
because of the quality of the tenants
and the underlying real estate at what
point do you say hey we want to go from
just buying things that we can afford to
like let's go build an actual business
here and raise capital and like
operationalize this yeah i mean it was a
full year we we bought
the first four plex and then another one
and then we brought in one investor and
then another and it was a year of buying
these little four unit buildings
and a full year later i spoke to a few
different people in the business and
they're like you could create a real
sizable scalable business doing this
like real estate syndication business so
we went out and we bought a 78 unit
building and people ask how did you make
that jump essentially i brought on two
gray hair partners that helped me one um
being my father he helped us qualify for
the larger loans because we didn't have
the balance sheet we couldn't qualify he
helped us by his law firm did all the
legal work and then he helped us with
his reputation uh by bringing in family
friends to invest with us or clients of
his firm and then we brought in another
gentleman named adrian who had a lot of
experience running larger multi-family
properties so we put together a little
group of eight people we went and bought
this uh 78 unit building in bakersfield
at the time it was like 3.9 million we
raised 1.3 million of equity from around
eight people uh our like acquisition fee
we just rolled back into the deal didn't
really take any money out and that's how
we learn just with good mentors and
partners and you know just kept rinsing
and repeating one deal at a time how
much harder is it to do a four unit
acquisition for 78 unit acquisition so i
always tell newcomers it's the same
amount of time and energy to buy
and renovate and oversee a small
building as compared to a big one in
some
circumstances the bigger ones are
actually easier to operate because they
have on-site professional management and
the maintenance techs on site and it's
it's um more efficiently run actually
and you can make more money you know the
bigger the property versus the smaller
ones so uh we we've just been over the
years pushing the envelope trying to buy
larger and larger properties um and it's
it's it's worked yeah and how did you
think you said it was about 3.9 million
uh you raised 1.3 million in equity and
then
took out debt for the rest how did you
think about the ratio there and why that
specific ratio yeah um we uh you know we
kept it at the time you could have got
higher leveraged loans just because the
cash flows were so great and prices were
pretty depressed um
we always stress test the deals and
we're like okay what happens if rents
drop you know 5 10 15 20
um what happens if occupancy drops you
know from 96 to 88 or whatever and you
know
when does that break even point occur
and then when you're in the negative and
we're very conservative we raise a lot
of extra money up front so if there is a
time when there's downturn and like we
had in 2020
we've been doing this now 13 years we've
never had any months where we actually
had we're in the negative until uh covet
hit and then collections started
suffering on two or three properties we
were in the negatives but instead of
going to investors and being like we
need to you know cover the mortgage
payment we had ample reserves in each
bank account to to fund that you know
for extended period of time um
but uh i'm rambling on a little bit well
when you think about that it's
interesting right like you go and you
raise extra equity up front what does
that do to the financial return does
that improve the return or is there it
lowers it a tiny bit but
what we
my pitch to investors is it's capital
preservation i never want to take a
permanent loss of capital in the game of
compounding
it kills your returns by having that
permanent loss right so instead of
hitting a 15 irr i'd be happy with a
14 irr and just consistently not ever
having a zero you don't want to it's a
it's different game than the vc game
where you actually want zeros you want
to take the highest risk and
you know invest in companies that are
out there and and maybe other people
don't see something and sure a lot of
them are going to go to zero but and
that's why you do it as a as a portfolio
you have a lot of them 20 30 40 whatever
angel investments if you see in real
estate it's like you know you're not
going to hit the 100x 000x but you're
going to have you know over 10 years 3 x
4x maybe 5x and if you bought an 09 you
know some buildings could be a 10x with
cash flow and equity appreciation but
also also all the tax benefits which a
lot of people don't understand using
depreciation and the ability to 1031
exchange and we're going to get to taxes
in a second before we do that uh talk to
me about what the average return looks
like so when you guys go by now you guys
are buying hundreds of units in a single
property is this something where you
guys go in and say hey our down the
fairway you know a great deal looks like
we buy x number of units and it's a
three x return in five years like how do
you think about this is what we're
looking for yeah um our strategy's
changed a little since inception so like
09 10 11 we were buying a lot of
buildings that were older built in the
60s 70s that that's where we saw the
opportunity um over the years we found
it it was hard to hold those buildings
long term they were just getting really
old and had major you know plumbing
issues and you know big repair
big-ticket items where and now in the
last few years we've been exchanging
those into like 2010 and newer buildings
primarily that we could hold longer term
that does they don't have those capital
needs plus the return profile like um
we're pretty similar between the newer
ones and the older ones so we're taking
the time to prune the portfolio sell off
a lot of those older buildings exchange
into the newer ones and also
geographically we're heading back to
california where you know the
the headlines oh you know political risk
people are leaving yadda yadda but risk
adjusted now the returns are actually
higher there than in other markets like
a phoenix or vegas why why are there
people
people are scared that you know and
right now phoenix is on fire and rents
are growing but it's always been
historically a very boom and bust market
same as vegas you know uh when it's uh
vegas relies on the gaming sector you
know for the economy and phoenix has
diversified a good amount and there's
ton of people moving there but you know
it's if you look back historically
during the last recession
rents dropped 20 in phoenix from peak to
trough and there were buildings that
were you know half vacant um they had an
immigration bill passed around 100 000
people left the the city it was uh blood
in the street and that's when we when we
went in there no 9 10 i'm sure we'll be
back into these markets when there's a
you know the next correction it's a
cyclical it's going to happen again at
some point i don't know when and how but
you know yeah when you look at uh buying
one of these properties how much of it
is uh hey we just want to buy the
property we want to get the cash flow
the tax benefits and then the capital
appreciation versus uh i think you guys
have also built other companies that
service uh
firms like yourself but also service
properties like how do you think about
almost like the empire building aspect
of this yeah so
i am pretty always thinking and
opportunistic and curious and um we did
other asset classes so like we were into
the mobile home park space for a while
uh we bought eight mobile home parks we
bought an rv park in in monterey that
did really well um what i've learned
over the years is really focus and you
know if you focus it'll just compound
and your energy and everything will be
on that one thing so we did well on
those mobile home products for the most
part but it just took away our energy
from our core business of you know
buying apartment buildings uh building
apartment buildings we also started
doing self storage which was actually
done really well we're probably going to
continue just you know doing that a
couple deals a year every year on that
front as well um but i've learned that
concentration and focus is really
important we did start a company called
demusso i think you're alluding to so we
saw a big need in our industry to help
help the property managers and landlords
go 100 digital collections of rent right
now you know people have a checkbook
sent sometimes just to pay one check a
month rent otherwise why even have that
checkbook there's so it's so antiquated
so we're helping our our our management
companies and other ownership groups
like ourselves help transfer them to
digital age and go 100 uh digital
collections we're active on 350 000
units so gelt is a customer but we have
a lot of the other top 50 uh like
property management companies as
customers and we're processing north of
five billion a year in rental payments
and that company's growing really
quickly i'm not involved in the day to
day but we helped seed it i'm on the
board and um we just saw a need in our
space to do that opportunity yeah i had
um chris from fort on and one of the
things that he said that i just stuck
with me was he's like you know look i
spent a lot of time company building
right like i'm an investor and when we
buy real estate uh you strike me as very
similar as well like there's a lot of
other things other than just like is
this a good deal or is it not there's
fundraising there's organization there's
hiring there's all these things talk to
me about that aspect of what you do on a
day-to-day basis like where do you spend
the most amount of your time yeah it's a
great question so in the beginning it
was just me and my cousin we had to do
everything ourselves but even from then
we sort of delegated well he was more of
the called the inside guy dealing with
the actual construction of the property
in rehab and dealing with the
contractors and i was more the outside
guy dealing with the brokers and
fundraising and the lawyers and so we
had good division of labor from the
beginning and then we just kept hiring
up one person at a time uh where we
needed to to where we weren't the best
at that and it wasn't the best use of
our time so we hired asset managers and
then accounting people and acquisitions
and just kept growing where we had holes
and where also our time wasn't best
spent so a lot of people get stuck in
micromanaging and doing everything
themselves and but it limits the type of
organization you could build so today
you fast forward to today my role 100 is
just fundraising pretty much at when
we're buying a building at the end you
know we have uh the investment committee
we discuss my partners and i but
ultimately i'm really just involved in
fundraising i'm not involved in the uh
asset management you know operationally
uh i have a partner that oversees the
staff um i have a partner that oversees
like construction management and i i'm
pretty much focused on just fundraising
for these deals real estate is very
capital intensive you gotta have a lot
of cash to buy it you're popular on
twitter uh that's the first time i ever
came across you uh is uh talk to me
about the fundraising strategy like what
like what where have you found success
and what hasn't worked yes so man i mean
when we first started my cousin damian
and i were in the car listening to
napoleon hill think and grow rich and
like we're figuring out how do we raise
our first hundred thousand dollars to
buy these little four plexes and it was
like wow we you know we didn't know we
had never raised money before but
raising money is really an art and i
think
i keep learning every day and how to
master that art i think
you know we started with family friends
and then clients of my dads and
my sphere of influence you know you
start with your circles like i'm in la
i'm in the jewish community i'm in ypo
i'm in tiger 21 i'm
you know and now twitter opens the
audience to the world right so i've been
meeting people from all walks of life
and in different parts of the country
that i would never have gotten in front
of and i'm not salesy at all i just like
to talk about what i do you know educate
people and if they're interested in
participating then they could reach out
to me and and
we have a lot of people that have
reached out from those kind of mediums
you know linkedin twitter i go on
podcasts like yourself and i meet really
cool people like that
i become friends with from that
what is the normal process look like so
you guys uh identify a deal you say this
is interesting do you have to fundraise
before you go put the loi do you like
just walk me through like how do you
actually acquire it and then what does
the timeline and sequence look like from
a fundraising standpoint yeah so the
process is you know we we get my
acquisition guy we look at like 100
deals out of 100 deals we'll maybe offer
on 5 to 10 and hopefully get one you
know awarded to us once we're awarded a
deal we're negotiating a purchase and
sale agreement um we simultaneously are
doing all of our physical inspections
lease file audit due diligence we're
putting together the offering memorandum
once that's done we send that out to the
investor base so it's literally an email
blast that goes to we have around 14 or
1500 current investors and then i have
another maybe 3 000 people that are that
have voice interest that just haven't
pulled the trigger yet um once we send
that out it's sort of like a
first come first serve commit and then
um usually we we call the funds within a
few weeks if anyone's late past the
deadline we then open it up to the
waiting list um to make it fair for
other people that didn't get to get in
but you know we're a little too slow to
commit and then we close on the
transaction usually around 60 days from
inception from signing the contract to
close um
i'd say
you know we we it's a little scary
raising money deal by deal because we
don't have
quote-unquote like discretionary
committed capital like a fund would so
we take on some risk but we have large
lines of credit and our own cash to
backfill if we ever are short um on a
raise which typically doesn't happen
anymore but it's still could
theoretically and uh our deals are
getting bigger and bigger so we we um we
have to keep ample you know liquidity to
be able to do that just in case why not
raise a discretionary fund it's a great
question so i think a fund with tax
paying people i don't think real estate
is a good vehicle to do a fund i think
for like vc and private equity for real
estate i think it should be done deal by
deal because
you never really if you do sell you
always want a 1031 exchange and roll
that over to avoid to defer paying the
tax i think um if you're in a fund it's
like a 10-year lifespan and then boom
you have to sell all the assets why sell
these golden geese lane golden eggs real
estate's like a generational kind of
thing you want to you know i'm not into
the never sell camp because we do sell
occasionally but
don't sell ever and return money but
then you have the the capital gain tax
plus something called recapture so all
the money you've been saving in in um
taxes over the years from the
depreciation comes to a head and then
you got to pay that out so like
let the money compound without the tax
man getting his pound of flesh right and
that way we could do this doing deal by
deal in a fund you know it's a 10-year
thing and um it would make it easier
fundraising like getting committed
capital and then calling it over time
and stuff but and then also on a fund
you have to deploy the capital within a
certain amount of time and you're gonna
be you're gonna be doing deals you
probably shouldn't be doing it you're in
a fun business versus like real estate
business let's talk about the tax
benefits of real estate so when you go
and you acquire one of these large
apartment complexes uh what are the
benefits you get up front in terms of
you make the purchase and within some
you know 60 90 120 days what are the
benefits yeah um you have something
called depreciation and what we do is um
cost segregation accelerated
depreciation uh you pay for a report
like i think we use cbre or other firms
and they'll you know break down the
components of the building into
different 10-year lifespan this and it
accelerates the depreciation so you
create
really large losses in the first year
and
you could use that you know those losses
to um offset any income from from real
estate income if you're if you're not a
real estate professional if you're a
real estate professional you could use
those losses against any income so i
always always recommend if someone could
qualify as a real estate professional
they should talk to their cpa and figure
out if they could do that what is the uh
definition of that the biggest uh hurdle
is like the hours you have to spend like
over 700 hours a year but i know people
that have married you know real estate
professionals and then like they they
use the losses from the real estate
against their spouses uh you know income
from whatever they do and it's um
you know it's a pretty
effective way to save money and it's
legal yeah what is the uh depreciation
that you get from use these cost
segregation studies and for this they
don't know
the doors okay we're going to appreciate
that over 10 years rather than 30. we're
going to the windows the doorknobs like
all kinds of crazy stuff
if you buy something for let's say 100
million dollars what is the percentage
usually that you can get depends on the
location how much building versus land
you can't depreciate the land but a real
life example we bought a building in
ventura uh california it was around 12
million dollar purchase price it created
losses in the first year of around three
million dollars which means uh
you could use like if you have three
million of income if you're a real
estate professional you could use that
three million of losses and it wipes
that out completely um
and uh
or or if you're not a real estate
professional you could use it against
other real estate uh income yeah so and
that flows through to our investors like
let's say you know an investor puts in
five percent of the money on a deal they
get five percent of those losses on
their k1 and we've had deals for many
years that are still showing losses the
first year you create that huge loss
with that cost egg but then it's i think
it's over 27.5 years if it's like a
multi-family kind of building it's a on
a straight-line depreciation schedule
and uh yeah it's pretty pretty wild so
right after the first per the initial
purchase you get the cost segregation so
you get the big bonus depreciation and
then what are the tax benefits as you
continue owning that property yeah it's
it's it drops from that first year but
it's still like
you know the the over 27 half year um
you you know and if you spend a lot of
money doing the rehab and stuff you you
could write that off also so it's um
i've had buildings five six years that
even though they're throwing off you
know seven eight nine ten fifteen
percent whatever cash flow they're still
showing losses because of that line item
it's a phantom expense you're not
actually spending it but you expense it
and um eventually yeah when you sell a
building if you take the cash you'll
have to all those savings of the taxes
over the years is called recapture you
then have to pay it but if you exchange
and don't take any money you know roll
100 of the proceeds into a like a like
size property uh it's like same size or
larger you have to replace the debt
essentially and and the equity and yeah
you you just keep kicking the can down
the road and then when you pass there's
a step up in basis for your errors and
stuff which is pretty so this is this is
the game this is the game man the rich
play this game and like you know anyone
with
that's an accredited investor you're
saying you're saving money you know i
recommend parking money in real estate
with with uh good sponsors you could buy
your own properties too we have
investors that purchase their own
properties and invest with us there's no
right or wrong explain in more detail
the 1031 exchanges i think a lot of
people don't understand uh how much of a
game changer this is yeah i'll give a
real life example so uh six years ago we
bought a large property in denver for 74
million it was like 500 some units and
um we just sold it uh in january of this
year for 141 million so it was a huge
gain
the investors i don't know maybe 4x plus
uh net of fuse and stuff they
they had the opportunity to roll that
into a brand new building we bought uh
in downtown long beach that was in lease
up and um
yeah
you know most investors will roll with
us uh into the next opportunity and they
didn't pay any taxes on that and over
time you know our goal we could pull out
uh principle through refinancing events
which uh when these loans loans come due
you have to pay it off so you either get
a new loan or sell the property we'll
get a new loan and pull out cash
hopefully get a bigger loan than the
previous loan and those um dollars also
are tax deferred then it's uh uh refi
proceeds loan proceeds it's not
considered income so that way is another
way to get money and principal out i
know people that have had buildings 30
years that you know like they pull out
so much money on these things and and
they still have the asset and they sell
the asset yeah i i have a mentor that
bought a building 30 years ago for 3
million dollars maybe put 600 grand down
him and his investors and now every year
the property throws off three million
dollars it's pretty remarkable plus you
know he's pulled out millions and
millions of dollars it's the ultimate
long game for for preserving wealth and
growing wealth safely uh risk best risk
adjusted returns in my mind why do they
have the tax code like this
that's something i i don't i can assume
it's just because the voting people you
know the people with the money they
lobby for this it's it's is it that or
is it because they actually want to
incentivize investment or
those are the two same things right it
does incentivize investment for sure and
this type of investment
um
i i just look i legally take advantage
of of whatever is legal tax wise you
know push the envelope and make sure
it's kosher and legal and this is all in
the tax code and you know we're doing it
yeah one of the messages that we have
for people almost on a daily basis is
like uh there's this thing in america
where people are like oh the tax people
you know the rich people aren't paying
taxes they're not paid and it's like
hold on a second there's not two tax
books there's not like rich people get
one set of rules and other people get a
different set of roles it's the
code is there for everyone to use
correct now there are things where hey
you got to own a business well okay
people figured out if i own a business i
get certain things or i got to own real
estate or you know it's not just if you
are a w-2 employee you have all these
things available to you you have to put
yourself in a position to benefit from
certain rules
but the rules are there and so you said
it earlier it's like rich people are
doing this like go learn how to do it
and then you can do exactly what they're
doing like the rules are available to
you as well right yeah for sure um
they make it a little tougher though for
like we only can work with like
accredited investors right so you have
to earn i think it's over 250 000 a year
or have a net worth of a million dollars
excluding your personal residence
there's still millions and millions of
people that will qualify for that but um
yeah it makes they make it harder i
think some you have to go through
certain procedures to be able to accept
money from non-accredited investors
which some sponsors do and stuff but um
definitely you know once
you become accredited it opens the doors
to that but yeah to build wealth you
know i think naval had a great threat on
this you know talking about how to
create wealth and it's literally owning
equity you know creating
business investments you know it's it's
tough when you're uh w-2 for sure to to
um you know you pay a lot in taxes and
but everything if you were able to save
you should be invested in over a long
period of time if you if you do the math
and compound it market you know eight to
ten percent kind of returns if you
invest in indexes it creates wonders
over a long period of time talk to me
about the current real estate
environment like obviously we had a zero
percent interest rate environment
mortgages et cetera was so cheap they
were trying to incentivize people to go
borrow and uh invest or spend capital uh
we now have kind of swung the other way
and uh we obviously have over you know
five five and a half percent residential
mortgage rates uh what are you seeing in
the market changing maybe between you
know summer of 2021 and now summer of
2022. yeah so i mean real estate
you can't just lump it all together but
like from what we're looking at
multi-family 200 unit and up denver and
west stuff we're buying prices are off
around 5 to 10
and it's not because the fundamentals
are slowing down like rent growth is
i've never seen rent growth like this i
mean we're seeing in some markets it's
like 20 year-over-year rent growth um
the problem is the interest rates have
risen so quickly it just puts a damper
on on the returns when you do your
modeling and um yeah we're borrowing at
now around
four and a half percent on a ten-year
fix whereas it was like sub three
percent you know
pretty recently um does that change your
appetite to go buy things that big of a
difference yeah we're more cautious now
um
we if we are buying like we're buying
one deal now we're buying it with only
uh 55
loan um so very conservative you know
leverage amounts um we're doing we're
still selling and exchanging but on new
cash we're sort of
very cautiously optimistic now it's like
i think the inflation thing is a real
story that should be
how does that impact uh
either assets you already own or assets
you're looking at like so if there's
high inflation that's probably driving a
lot of the rent growth right yeah but
eventually people aren't going to be
able to afford these things and like the
the cap rates will will rise too and
that puts a damper on values so
um i think uh
we've had a double whammy over the last
10 years of cap rates compressing uh
which means it's like multiples the
multiple's expanding and uh rents and
rent's growing but now i think you're
gonna see the cap rates started popping
up a little bit uh along with interest
rates and um if rent growth slows a
little bit there's gonna be some
you know issues especially with some of
these borrowers that are doing these um
short-term like variable loans that are
high leverage and stuff it do you think
that uh there could be a re um
do you think that there could be a
recreation of the 2008 2009 crisis where
there's like over leveraging the system
and prices go down and everyone's
screwed or do you think we're not there
i don't think it will probably be at
that level but um
you know on on the uh single fam because
people generally on single family for
example are putting more down
payment and they're um you know
financially more secure in oh six or
whatever and everyone in their mom was
able to get a mortgage you know so i'd
say i'm starting to see houses sit
longer it's going to lead to price cuts
the inventory is low though so that'll
you know help also the soften the blow
but definitely mortgage payments have
doubled like you know i was lucky enough
i refined my house and i locked rate
right before this run-up but it's it
would have doubled my mortgage payment
if i didn't do you know
have luck
of locking in time and um you know plus
the stock market being down is double
whammy people have less perceived wealth
i mean it fluctuates but right now if
they
were worth
a hundred dollars it's now they're worth
80 or if they were in a lot of the tech
heavy stocks maybe they're worth you
know 50 60 on that 100 so it's
definitely wealth is down there's a lot
of real estate folks uh that i've talked
to or you know i i hear their various um
kind of thoughts
don't buy your primary home rent and
then go buy the investment properties
how do you think about it is that good
advice bad advice is it case dependent
like when you're starting like i always
tell people
our investors if they don't own their
home yet i think owning a home is a good
you know thing and and uh
you know certain countries it's there's
more renters versus homeowners and
at one time i remember the stat was like
i think we were up to a 69 percent uh
home home ownership before the 009
recession it dropped to like 60 for
every point of drop in home ownership it
was like a million new renter households
that were formed i think it's crept up a
little bit but
um yeah i always recommend you know it's
it's
stability having a home and you know
it's generally people's largest
investment because it's a forced savings
right they pay the mortgage down over
the years and it appreciates in value
and
i mean it depends where the home is at
and stuff but like in certain parts of
la or probably all la would have been a
great investment over the time um it
just depends like you know if you need
the
cash to you know do other things with
but um if you have the cash
and you have the you know amount of
money to
service the debt and then some buy buy a
house i think it's okay
you mentioned 10-year fixed rate uh
debt earlier is that what you guys
normally target yeah so that yeah
primarily ten-year fixed um we could get
a little longer term probably but um the
negative thing is they have these big
prepayment penalties on the loan so
um but we're very conservative shop so
like we've been doing those since
inception and when we went to sell
buildings the the buyers they didn't
want to assume those loans because they
were above market interest rate now um
yeah we locked in a rate at 2.99 that's
way below market so it is
you know people would assume that and
it'll add a lot of value to the purchase
i think but we did it really just to
have
sanity and know for 10 years this is
your mortgage payment and like you know
and it forces you to hold long term when
you put on slap on those long-term fixed
rate loans and i think real estate the
way to create that wealth is holding
buildings long-term and you know playing
the long game versus
flipping you know when do you know to
sell
um we sold for different reasons so the
first few years we sold to create a
track record um we did return capital to
the investors versus exchanging nowadays
we only try to exchange we have that
track record um
we sold because some of the buildings
are getting too old and have major you
know capital needs and we'd rather
exchange into newer buildings and
what other reasons to sell if the loan's
coming due and we feel like it's a good
time to you know place the money into
something else we'll sell um but
typically yeah try not to sell to too
often i want to ask a couple of
questions you tell me if you can't talk
about it or don't want to uh
when you go to get a loan
how many financial institutions do you
talk to do you make them compete with
each other like how do you optimize as a
real estate investor to make sure that
you're getting the best we always go
through a mortgage broker for sure um
yeah typically
so if uh the investment sales team is
like let's say cbre we have contacts at
cbre that that are they handle you know
the mortgage brokerage and farming it
out you know making the different
lenders compete to try to get the best
you know price terms uh etc um yeah we
always you we feel like that's a cost
that's that's worth paying so you guys
go through a broker you don't do it
directly correct yeah why you go through
the broker um just because they make the
lenders compete you know we we and
nowadays a lot of the loans we were
getting were agency fannie and freddie
but now we have life companies involved
in the mix banks debt funds like a lot
of different you know lending
institutions and um they really
you know make them compete and we get
the best uh
best value you know for doing that when
you look at a deal what is like the one
or two metric you think are the most
important to pay attention to yeah we're
into you know something that's an ideal
deal for gel we we want to see it cash
flowing from day one or able to have
meaningful cash flow fairly quickly
through some kind of renovation program
uh we model conservative rent growth uh
typically we're not a pioneer and we're
not the first one to you know upgrade
units in a certain market we have comps
that show that you know if we upgrade
the unit this is what the kind of rent
we'll achieve um
and um
yeah and we uh we do it with moderate
leverage we try to you know hit like a
two and a half to three x equity
multiple over ten years is sort of like
the with a conservative underwriting
that's what we're trying to hit um
we've seen a lot greater than that just
because of the market um but uh yeah i
think i think during tough times you're
gonna see you know who are the real
players and who could withstand the
tough times and versus the people have
just been
momentum guys you know in a uh recent
interview with uh the hustle you
mentioned this like flight the quality
uh that you saw during cove explain that
um i i think you're referring to uh like
the
property quality and stuff yeah like
people like there was a flight to
quality in terms of what people were
looking for
yeah um especially us i mean we saw a
lot of uh struggles on the portfolio of
the buildings that were more blue collar
lower income um
you know collections were lower in those
kind of markets so
we sort of peeled off some of these
troubled buildings that that were having
hard collection issues and also the
deferred maintenance and capex needs and
exchanging into a lot newer vintage
buildings and better locations where
collections remain a lot higher those
people weren't as affected by covid with
job loss and um we also are trying to
buy in more areas with higher barriers
to entries like southern california as
well when you have a deal how much cash
do you try to keep in the bank uh and
i'll measure it maybe in like months of
covering a mortgage or if there is some
sort of downturn et cetera is this
something that you think of it somewhere
like an individual hey we need three to
six months of like a rainy day fund or
how do you yeah we definitely keep a
reserve like slush fund rainy day fund i
learned that early on um from my mom
actually who who did some real estate
investment my parents own some
properties and they're like you you
always want to have that you know
reserve so um it's not like a
definite number it
differs deal by deal we'll let it drop a
little bit over time if the deal is
really doing really well and it's in
good shape but yeah we typically on
these large deals
we'll keep you know at least a million
bucks or so like you know in the bank
sitting there so we have a lot of
cushion and room to go before we have to
do any capital call we've never had a
capital call um in the history of our
firm on some of the construction
projects we've gone over budget and
we've lent personal capital to the deal
so we don't have to you know go to the
investors and bother them but we've
we've prided ourselves on never having a
capital call and never losing a dollar
of principle for the investors and we
plan to keep it that way i love that uh
i asked for questions from twitter and
uh they did not disappoint us so i'm
sure you know so i'm just gonna read
through and we'll do kind of rapid fire
here tyler hogue said how can you assess
whether a real estate investor is any
good when essentially everyone made
money over the last decade yeah that was
a great question i like that one from
tyler um
yeah
i think
there's a lot of people that have made a
lot of money just from you know
leveraging up like crazy and the
market's been good and but during the
tough times coming up pretty soon here
you're going to see you know who who
who's uh whatever this buff is saying is
you know swimming water goes out yeah
when the water goes out so i think and
there's some people that actually
were you know in the wrong kind of asset
classes not everyone in real estate made
money most of people in multi-family did
and but i know people that you know if
you look at some of these office tower
trades they they're trading for lower
dollars than they were 10 years ago even
like it just depends on the type of real
estate you've been buying but we've had
tailwinds and multifamily
you know with huge rent growth and
i think um
definitely
the more conservative shops like us that
are planning to be multi-decade and you
know
we're always prepared for the worst um
we're going to be able to go through
these tougher times versus people that
are more transactional
buying and selling and flipping and um
so so far yeah those groups are okay but
they could have a world of pain if uh
you know things change with this it
seems like it's happening right now omar
morales asked uh is he a net seller or
net buyer this year that's a great
question so
omar is my buddy here in bercadia here
locally miami great guy shout out to
omar the hardest working uh broker i
know 28 years old very successful uh
very curious love that guy um i'd say
net seller probably we have a lot of
properties on the chopping block um most
of them we're going to try to exchange
though
so that
produces a buy but
yeah i know some very smart
groups that have a different structure
they're more fun and stuff and they've
been net sellers um especially in this
very low cap rate environment they were
selling stuff last year for like three
caps and everywhere even in the midwest
and stuff where historically you don't
see a lot of rent growth so uh some of
the smartest money i see are are selling
right now yeah uh audi asked if you
could go back in time and change one
decision you've made along the way which
one would it be and why
it's a great question um
the one that eats away at me the most is
selling our phoenix portfolio we had
2500 units in phoenix we sold in around
2017. uh values have over doubled since
then and um i mean everything we then
use that money to buy has gone up too
but like phoenix has been on fire and
that sort of burns me we'll be back in
that market at some point but um
you know that's the one that got away
yeah that's okay you did okay yeah bijon
mateens asked what's your opinion about
fractionalized real estate investments
through nft technology
that's an interesting one i mean i i
don't know enough to talk about that but
i think there is you know real estate
sort of industry that
doesn't change much with technology too
quickly
um there are some interesting kind of
prop tech companies out there and stuff
um it's gonna be interesting to watch
we'll see if that's is that the killer
use case how's that gonna work i see a
lot of like decks on people trying to do
stuff like this but none of them have
taken off really yet but we'll see
ricky excuse me ricky schmidt asked uh
i'm a real estate broker in charleston
south carolina currently there's 1700
houses in inventory the average
pre-pandemic was 5500 to 6500 so about
20 or so uh loaning standard and home
equity is higher than ever uh soften
from euphoria yes but where do people
think the inventory to crash the market
will come from
yeah that's a great question um yeah i
got like the smartest audience on
twitter oh man you got some good people
following you for sure
um i'd say yeah the inventory
percentage-wise it shot up a lot but
historically it's still very low he's
saying um
but they're they're you know
the i don't know if it'll be inventory
that crashes the market or just the
right if the rates just keep rising i
mean that's going to put a damper on
home values and i think it'll um it'll
damper the crazy growth we've seen in
home values but it might even lead to
some not just softening but some decline
in value but definitely uh you know you
need to see probably more inventory but
that person that's a big percentage jump
and it could continue probably yeah uh
somebody who uh they're
not actually using a name said uh for a
couple with young kids who wants to buy
a house in the next couple of years what
are some recommendations to prepare that
we might not think of they're already
trying to get out of debt raise their
credit score and increase income but
what else could they be doing just buy a
house with within your means right i
mean you don't want to buy something
bigger than you could chew that you're
like struggling to make the mortgage
payment and like you want to sort of
live under your means and then you could
always buy a bigger house at a future
date right like um
and uh don't
like
in one of my mentors like in the next
two three four years the house or the
real estate could be worth less than
you pay for it but but who cares in the
long run it's gonna be worth more in in
terms of income producing property the
the cash flows can be a lot greater over
the years and uh you got to have that
long-term mindset it same as the stock
market right if you're buying a good
company and you you got to set it and
forget it right like you could be down
all the best companies have had big
drawdowns over the years i mean
the most notable one amazon had like a
90 drawdown i don't know how many people
had had the stomach to withstand that
and hold it but if you did you'd be up a
gazillion percent you know yeah bezos
did
mr bezos did and look at them now big
basil exactly uh veronica y who says my
country is a developing country where
population is still growing uh stably
we've never experienced a housing market
crash like in the u.s uh investment is
still deemed uh investment in property
is still deemed a safe haven uh and then
she says is u.s property investment
still a good investment due to u.s
declines of population and maybe i'll
edit a little bit of like how do you
think about real estate along with
population growth or contraction yeah i
mean one of the biggest mistakes we made
is we bought in a small community where
there was flat population it wasn't
growing and we weren't able to really
push rents aggressively um
it was when we were trying to go into
the mobile home park space and with a
big
bash and we bought like a 400 space
three-part portfolio in rural
pennsylvania and you know at the time it
looked good on paper but there was no
rent growth so we try to buy in areas
that are growing and you know there are
cities in the us that like are shrinking
we try to avoid those kind of areas we
try to buy in areas that are growing and
if they have higher barriers to entry
that's that's a that's even better so um
but you real estate in the us is a safe
haven we have a lot of international
investors that park money here because
of our political stability and maybe
they could have higher returns
potentially in other
kind of developing countries but u.s is
like i mean i'm biased but i think the
best country the safest place to park
capital still and um
i think it'll continue to be
uh somebody named scam balls
uh asked
what you think about metaverse real
estate and will you buy some
i mean i'm i'm
i like the concept of nfts and you know
i think there's gonna be a lot more cool
companies that are formed with really
killer use cases and i'm an early
adopter i bought my crypto punk like i
don't even know like i first heard the
um a podcast with uh what's his name one
of these big vc guys that was talking
about it um
i forget that kevin uh kevin rose kevin
so yeah i i'm like wow this is pretty
cool so i had a few bucks in coinbase
sitting there and i'm like it doesn't
bring me much enjoyment and this little
crypto punk nft it's like art and i
bought that and it went up like 10x and
then it's back down but um with the
metaverse and land i mean
there's like i don't know
i feel like there's unlimited it could
just create more and more just like you
could create more and more nfts that's
why i'm like i only buy the iconic one
like one of the first projects i'm not
going and buying any you know pfp 10 000
you know i think there's gonna be a
gazillion of them but there will be some
you know over the decades things that
were done early on that'll be like wow
this is has historical value and people
you know
relate to it and like it but um yeah i
haven't bought any land in the metaverse
and stuff but i think i feel like with
with um there's gonna be more like
you know facebook they change their
whole name to meta right they're betting
the future on that and it's coming you
know with the
glasses and being out and about and
having you know the
the augmented reality and different
forms of advertising to people and it'll
it'll uh make life it's gonna be
different for sure yeah punk three zero
five four asked uh
what your worst decision in business
will hold the answer you already said
but uh your best decision in your
personal life
oh that's a great question
best decision in my personal life was uh
marrying my wife i was gonna say man you
gotta say that
you're gonna get in trouble yeah no i
mean i i uh she's fantastic i i totally
married up i mean i i i love that we
created this cake together she's like my
biggest fan i push her she pushes me
we've created a beautiful life together
with three amazing children
we work together pretty much she
spearheads all the ground-up development
for us um she her projects that she
spearheads are some of her best
performing ones you don't see a lot of
female developers and i think she's very
conservative in nature and always plans
what's the worst case scenario and um
she's hit it out of the park she she
buys in areas that are like
changing and she follows where all the
restaurants are going and fall sees
where they're getting permits and stuff
and she's really early and um
she's a prolific developer she's done
really well and
she's an amazing person
uh four to eight asked at what point
during lockdowns in panic did keith and
gelt realize that they would bet big on
la when everyone else was leaving
and then the second question is work
life balance possible like actually
possible
yeah so the first question so when did
we start
doubling down on la we already had a few
projects in la and um
during la actually our our collections
were remain pretty robust um
our buildings in la are pretty high
quality and
either newer or major renovations and
they did well and we're like
yeah we just started seeing these other
markets that
got crazy heated and you know valuations
going kooky and we're like let's just
start buying more doubling down on not
just la but core infel socal i mean we
were we bought some great deals in long
beach in anaheim and we're looking in
you know all these sort of core southern
california markets um
where i feel like there's less bitters
on stuff now
and you know i think things are gonna
the pendulum swings la and socal it's
gonna it's always gonna be a great place
for people to live and raise family and
um you have some influx of people
leaving but i think you're gonna have
new people come in
um there was another question here uh
what were the trigger points that you
used to increase your team size like
when did you know to grow well that's a
great question um oh i forgot the
work-life balance on the last one um
work-life balance
um i'm a professional delegator so i
think i've created that work-life
balance and i get to work the hours i
want when i want and that's what true
financial freedom and wealth is right um
i have an excellent team that are
killers in the different you know
departments that that they're they're in
um but i think that whole remote we're
still remote i i'm allowing the team to
be remote and i think they're enjoying
it they don't have the hour commute each
way they're able to pick up their kids
if they want this hour they're working
probably more hours but on their own
time and terms not every job you could
do that obviously some have to be in
person you know with other people um and
dealing with customers that come in or
clients or whatnot but i'm a big
believer in uh giving people flexibility
and uh
you know they're they're still held
accountable and doing great work though
for us so i think light work life
balance is
it it's it's it's achievable um but
you gotta really manage your time
properly especially when you have kids
and stuff but i feel like i'm so much
better working in the hours i do work um
i'm not fooling around as much you know
i'm really working um growing team size
team size yeah we we just kept hiring
when we had holes and we needed you know
more people so like
it's pretty uh scalable in my business
because i don't do property management
we outsource that that that requires the
most people uh we would have probably
250 people if we did property management
we have 20. i'd rather have a smaller
team and not have to deal with personnel
issues hiring training firing and that's
what has helped us scale and really
focus on finding good investments and
and letting the day-to-day you know
collection of rent fixing repair
maintenance we oversee
the property management company you know
and make sure um they don't overspend
and every major ticket item we have to
approve and we oversee the major capex
items but the day-to-day operation we
let them do it and we pay them a fee um
but yeah we haven't
hired that i mean we have 20 some people
and every year we had like one or two
it's not like a huge need to hire up and
stuff which i like it's we hire we have
ton of applicants people that want to
work with us and we got to be choosy on
who we pick
uh i have two more questions one of them
is business related and one is
personally related but uh on the
business front your twitter bio
just says one word compounding yeah uh
why what what is it about compounding
why is that so important and why is that
i'm just enough to put as the only word
in your twitter bio yeah man i i like it
keeping it simple sweet and to the point
i'm uh i believe everything in life the
best things in life are compounding
relationships obviously investments um i
even got my tattoo recently you see this
little chart up to the right that's
compounding baby that's what we do
each one of these is mike there's five
of us for the five of us in our family
so it's double meaning but i feel like
consistent you know every day you put in
the work and make a little progress
every day and then it's like you look
back
10 years and it's pretty amazing you
know you don't see it day to day but
over the decades you see like wow this
is tremendous growth you know so i think
compounding is everything in life um
just being long-term most people are not
long-term thinkers being sticking to the
plan you know we talked about bezos you
got elon musk like just
spit sticking to the plan and uh
you know elon musk had that master plan
he put out there right when he started
it's been the same since day one he kept
focused on doing that you know starting
with the with the the first car the
roadster and then the the model s and he
had a whole plan on what he was gonna do
and he's stuck to it and um the best
thinkers are just ones that are
persistent and don't give up and just
keep compounding over time i love it um
one of our sponsors is eight sleep
what is your sleep schedule what what oh
man um what what do you do you you i
feel like have so much going on and
you're so effective at it yeah it's
tough with three kids that are waking me
up at all hours of the night
you know the the the 21 mo
21 month old you know he's crying for
milk in the night and then the
three-year-old is
he's lost his pasty in his crib or his
his
blanket's not folded right i mean we
yeah sleep is is important uh
not getting consistent sleep could make
you a little deranged i i need i need to
invest in an eight sleep bed as asap and
then some sleep training for for our
children but um yeah i i try to go to
bed at a reasonable hour i'm not one of
those at real time i go to bed probably
10 yeah late 11 at the latest and
probably sleep till 6 30ish and um so
you get eight hours yeah pretty much try
to get that yeah
my body i wouldn't function on four
hours like some people could do yeah um
which is i used to be able to do that
and now no more yeah it's it's it's not
worth it i mean
you're better off getting a good night's
sleep and being well rested and just
crushing it during the day versus you
know try to pack everything in
i am uh
i don't think that people understand the
sleep thing until they do it like when
you're younger i actually think there's
some like weird thing about like uh i
have so much to do at school like school
in america starts so early compared to
like many other places
and then it forces parents to get up
cause they gotta wake the kids up and
like all this stuff um but to some
degree once you
realize the power of sleep you're like
dude this is amazing what am i doing
yeah i agree we're we're transferring
our kid to a different school and it
starts like an hour later and
it's going to be better
man yeah that wasn't that wasn't the
reason but it was like that's pretty
cool yeah i love that um all right where
can we send people to uh to find you on
the internet or find out more about
guilt just just just hop on the twitter
to you know shoot me a message at dm
it's it's keith uh underscore wasserman
his twitter i'm active on linkedin is
another one um
shoot me an email it's keith
geltink.com g-e-l-t
dot com
um i'm i'm i'm open book and
if if you have any questions just try to
make it specific i get a lot of people
are like i have 10 to 15 minutes of your
time and i'm like no just go to go to
pumps podcasts i talk i'm on a lot of
podcasts you go listen listen to me but
ask me specific questions i'll give you
specific answers you know and and uh i
formed relationships with people over
over the years that have uh you know
that have done that so i love it i i
uh i'm enjoying watching you have fun
because i know i can tell that you're
having fun doing it you got to have fun
man we're having fun here you know we're
i know you're you're hard working man
back to back interviews i'm probably
number three or four for the day and uh
but you got to have fun you know you got
it that is the that's the whole key all
right well listen thank you so much for
coming on i hope everyone uh enjoyed
this if you don't know [ __ ] about real
estate he's a great guy to follow on on
twitter um
that's it that's all we got for you all
i appreciate every single one of you
i'll see you guys tomorrow thank you
everyone